[Applause]
all right sure me Daniels is now doing
comedy which is a step up from doing
porn
unless you're Seth Meyers anyone who
sits through his act always feels
screwed here's part of it I want to ask
about
Ilhan Oh Marc June he's bringing up the
two tweets that she's apologized for and
I think that's a little unfair to her
especially because we've established
what are you were a press person no I'm
just someone who who cares about the
fact that there's someone out there who
is in a minority who has had death
threats against her and I think that we
should all use the same language that
you're asking her to be careful about
her language and I would ask everybody
else to be careful about theirs that's a
comedian stormy stormy if that's your
competition you got nothing to worry
about
comedians it's the only thing Trump
didn't make great again instead instead
they're now shrill little Hall monitors
with tiny wrists stormy though now since
Trump wasn't as bad as her ex lawyer
Michael avenatti now when you regret
hiring your lawyer more than doing porn
that's a bad lawyer one who faces
centuries in jail so now Stormies doing
stand-up to earn a paycheck but at least
she's standing up to earn a paycheck
thank you
in other news the New York Times had a
big scoop Trump lost a bundle in the 90s
I know it's amazing also that movie home
alone looks like a hit and how how about
that Vanilla Ice guy huh mark my words
that fellas going places but I guess
when you can't find any news to match
your delusions
you'll make anything else news including
what Trump actually talked about 15
years ago about 13 years ago I was
seriously in trouble
I was billions of dollars in debt but I
fought back and I want
pigley good job times you really dropped
a bombshell a bombshell revealed to
millions of people on national TV over a
decade and a half ago
what other bombshells will The Times
glean from reality TV that Kim
Kardashian once wore leggings that would
have one of the real housewives through
a glass of merlot at another Real
Housewife that's someone on Survivor ate
a bug
so is it journalism when someone gives
you someone else's tax returns it's odd
no one in the media minds how The Times
got them but under Trump real news is
skipped for the old news because when
the real news is good the media's got to
find conflict in the past to make their
present bearable if only there were a
drug so Trump lost a bunch of money in
the 80s how is that news I mean I'm so
tired of the New York Times packaging
old news like it's new what are you
gonna tell me next Saddam Hussein
invaded Kuwait the Berlin Wall came down
how about Milli Vanilli was actually
lip-synching the media thinks we're
idiots you should talk to your doctor
you may be suffering from common sense
what's that
common sense is when you recognize old
news for what it is and see right
through the media's attempt to repackage
old garbage to push their own bias
narrative take a look at this what do
you see see this is from 1990 isn't
there a way to make this new and fresh
again there is thanks to throw it backs
for what Beck's tricks your brain into
thinking decades-old mundane news items
for a modern-day scandal by erasing all
of your long-term memory you'll be blown
away even by the most stale reporting
how does it do that
I already told you by erasing all of
your long-term
memory wait a minute I already took it
who are you anyway
I'm the announcer we've been doing the
same thing for three years
really yes we do an ad about a drug for
almost every monologue easy this stuff
really works
Wow this is unbelievable did you know
Trump has been married three times
also it says here he loves to golf he's
never gonna be elected he was elected in
2016 I must have missed that and look at
this since the whole city is getting
indoor plumbing now where's all the
water gonna come from and how about this
women expected to get the right to vote
I don't like that at all
you're an idiot I'm leaving you who are
you I'm your wife someone married me
that's awesome Thanks product whose name
I forget
so get throw it backs today making
everything old and new again
the point is the media drenched in its
own failure has to reanimate old fears
remember that story from months ago
about Trump never leaving office well
it's back he doesn't have any intention
of committing to a peaceful transition
of power how would you get a president
to leave if he just said I ain't leavin
wait what's it it joy who wouldn't leave
following some bad stuff revealed about
her past hmm if only the media could
find two words they could repeat over
and over again folks a constitutional
crisis a constitutional crisis do you
agree with congressman Nadler German and
annoyed that that we're in a
constitutional crisis we are ever wonder
what a constitutional crisis looks like
we'll open your eyes yeah it looks like
Don Lemon anyway so what is the crisis
really that they're out of ideas that
they all share the same script that
they're all sheep without the benefits
of supplying plush will sweaters you
think it bothers Trump now he's got
bigger concerns I have to tell you that
runway is like an ice-skating rink and
the first step I said you know this
sucker is slippery
I think it was put in by the Democrats
who gets the biggest clap I don't even
have to write this stuff it does feel
like a trap I don't know whoever the
hell got that thing that's not that's a
trap I'm telling you it's like it's like
ridiculous can you imagine if he went
down can you imagine if I went down the
press would have a field day for weeks
and weeks now it's like he's floating
around on a piece of ice as I stand here
floating around on a piece of ice this
is crazy I'm a little bit concerned
about leaving the podium I'm hoping you
have no idea what I'm going through on
this stage there's a worst damn stage I
wonder who did this one stupid people
did this one what brilliant they may be
the enemy so what kind of president
talks about the slippery stage that guy
the complete opposite of a politician
there's no phoney cadence no
regurgitating platitudes just his box on
slippery floors so now the media and the
Democrats accused Trump of the very
worst so what's the next stop on this
crazy train
let's review first stop was Trump's
unstable the second stop he's insane the
third stop he's a Russian spy who stole
the election the fourth stop he won't
leave office the fifth stop he created a
constitutional crisis so what's next
could trump be in Isis
and maroon 5 if the media wants you to
think there's an unstable tyrant
barricading himself in the Oval Office
then who's trying to create the crisis
really and to what end what do they want
to happen
it's sad they're still trying to undo
2016 instead of trying to win 2020
it's the losers response to losing
winners admit they're wrong and they
change but not here instead they just
dig a deeper grave as they reelect a
person who keeps handing them the
shovels he's got a fixation on
litigation attorney Fox News contributor
Emily gallo
he's like a sloppy less handsome Jonas
Brother writer and comedian and chris
fried three sheep this scamp who likes
that vamp host of the tyrants and Tim
podcast Katherine temp
he flosses with the transatlantic cable
in essence I get tyrus thoughts
constitutional crisis absolutely not I
feel like everyone all of these federal
elected officials are totally obsessed
with just taking downtown so they're not
legislating they're not doing their job
they're not doing anything that we pay
them to do and while they keep wasting
time doing that like you said 2020 is
coming closer and closer they will have
nothing to show for it and now they're
literally talking about codifying
putting into federal law essentially
things that will help get Trump
afterwards because they're never going
to let it go and while they are mired in
that our state legislators have been
busy also writing bills to make sure
that they can get Trump afterward and
all it's doing is going to affect us as
private citizens so it's codifying like
when you take a fish like you know what
it's like extra hugs for a baby
oh the coddling I'm confused Chris not a
caught fish you ugly caught fish what
Peter Pan that's cruel I know that word
as well as you know my last name
freed now everybody knows it he's his
best friend totally knows who he is
Chris right thoughts interests anything
interesting about the show in general I
just want to talk about your name I'd
like to talk about me some more what I
find interesting is that the media still
uses the word shocking when it's a
stormy Daniels story yeah and I don't
like it for it number one because most
things like if you get a pop-up stormy
Daniels with a shocked face chances are
what she's looking at gives you a virus
of some kind you can't click on it I
don't like that number one number two
it's just not shocking like it wasn't
shocking that Trump slept with her
either you know one thing was never
shocking no stupid a billionaire in New
York City who's had lots of flings
sleeping with a porn star I think that's
required yeah I don't know
not a question really but yeah I don't
know where you want me to go with it
are you happy she's doing stand-up I
feel like it's fine yeah that's good no
I go girls I liked it I coined that
phrase yeah I feel like it's fine I feel
like it's better than doing porn to do
stand-up it's a little more difficult so
best of luck to her yes there is nothing
worse than being on stage and trying to
tell jokes and having nobody laugh it's
really really quite sad but you know I
wish I wish her the best I really really
do and it's funny that her lawyer
avenatti obviously he's worse than Trump
what are they what are they even talking
about he stole money from people who
would paraplegic yes okay yeah Trump
lost 2 billion I lost my cat in my
apartment once sometimes you lose stuff
but all that matters is that you come
out on top no I found the cat he has a
career I was welded as well over and out
Pyrus last word to you I keep having
this style in my head I want to say
about stormy doing stand-up but I
normally in trouble yes don't think it's
not working they have a particular
person with a job title comes in and
makes it work yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
uh comedies you know it's tough it's
tough and maybe the audience maybe you
could help me the word constitutional
crisis mm-hmm they say it a lot but no
one asks how so right like exploit Don
Lemon if I was gonna guess in the show
which I would me but if I was I'd be
like what does it mean right constable
open your eyes okay they're open yes
what is it
it's their plain sight I don't know what
it is exactly is the Constitution
stressed out like what is yes what is
the crisis what they they use the term
with no definition it's you have I have
a constitutional crisis every day
[Applause]
the reality nor displayed it yeah no
one's a guy constitutional crisis how so
mine are whenever I'm cheese I'm not
gonna I'm not biting on that now yeah
wait founding fathers is either yeah
they're constitute crisis was England
showing up saying we're taking it back
yeah that's a constitutional crisis it's
so true
so yeah I'd love to please Domino if you
get a second no one's watching so if you
get a second